nos piden que graphic hemos igual al
logaritmo en base 5 de x y bueno esto es
exactamente lo mismo que decir que es
igual a la potencia que usted tiene que
elevar 5 para que nos dé x o si esto lo
vemos en su forma exponencial
podemos decir que estas dos expresiones
son equivalentes 5 es mi base y entonces
aquí tengo a james que va a pasar a ser
un exponente mientras que x va a ser mi
resultado esto mismo si lo vemos en su
forma exponencial tendremos que escribir
que 5 elevado al aiem es exactamente
igual que x esto es exactamente igual
que x sin embargo hay unas grandes
diferencias
solamente en percepciones de estas dos
funciones porque mientras que aquí
tenemos que x es una función de y aquí
arriba tenemos que ya es una función de
x dependemos de x sin embargo estas dos
cosas son exactamente lo mismo son dos
formas de ver el mismo problema por lo
tanto podemos trabajar con ambas y bueno
si yo lo que quiero es graficar esta
función
es lo que se me ocurre hacer es tomarme
algunos valores de x o de james y
entonces hacer una tabulación y de ahí
partir muy gráfica así que voy a poner
aquí a x y aquí voy a poner ella y qué
es lo que me conviene tomarme valores de
x y obtener valores de james o tomar en
valores de ley y obtener valores de x y
es que recuerda que este es un problema
con dos caras de la misma moneda porque
fíjate bien en este caso x es muy
variable independiente mientras que es
muy variable dependiente y depende de lo
que valga x mientras que en el caso de
abajo es lo contrario lleva a ser muy
variable e independiente mientras que x
es muy variable dependiente y va a
depender de lo que valga
james por lo tanto creo que me conviene
más verlo como de esta forma pensar en
variar la jep para obtener valores de x
mientras que aquí tendría lo contrario
tendría que tener valores de x para
obtener valores de james sin embargo yo
prefiero que trabajemos con la función
exponencial que ya conocemos ya hemos
trabajado con ella varias veces que
trabajar con la función logaritmo en la
cual todavía es un poco desconocida para
nosotros
y además es un poco más difícil de
aplicar y entonces vamos a variar la
yema y vamos a variar la gent o sea que
tenemos valores de menos 2 a 2 para ver
que obtenemos de x así que vamos a decir
que lle valen menos 2 déjame poner aquí
el otro valor menos 1 con otro color el
0 con otro color distinto el 1 y por
último el 2 con un color nuevo y
perfecto ya que tengo yo esto que me va
a quedar un valor de x en estos valores
de 10 para estos valores de jane
entonces fíjate si yo sustituyó ayer por
menos 2 aquí me quedaría 5 elevado a la
menos 2 y que x voy a obtener al elevar
5 a la menos 2 pues 5 elevado al menos 2
es lo mismo que uno en 35 al cuadrado
que es lo mismo que uno entre 25 un 25
por lo tanto cuando vale menos 2 x vale
un 25 agua así que déjame ponerlo aquí
cuando llévale menos 2x vale 1 sobre 25
o dicho de otra manera y no olvidemos la
forma de ugarit mika estoy diciendo que
el logaritmo en base 5 de 1 sobre 25 es
exactamente igual a menos 2 hay que
pensar
manera a qué potencia tenemos que elevar
el 5 para que me dé un 25
y la respuesta es menos 2 y bueno lo voy
a escribir acaba con forma exponencial
para que veas de dónde salió 5 elevado a
la menos 2 es igual a un 25 ago perfecto
así que vamos la siguiente potencia 5
elevado al menos 1 es igual a un quinto
o dicho de otra manera en lenguaje de
logaritmos logaritmo en base 5 de 1 hay
que tener mucho cuidado de un quinto es
igual a menos 1 recuerda 5 elevado a qué
potencia nos da un quinto y esto es
igual a menos 1 hay que tener mucho
cuidado con eso ahora vamos con el 05
elevado a la cero es 1 por lo tanto
cuando lleva de 0 x vale 1 o visto en
lenguaje de logaritmos 5 elevado a que
potencia me da 1 y bueno pues la
respuesta es 0 logaritmo en base 5 de 1
es cero ahora cuando llévale uno cuando
llama de uno pues x vale 55 elevado a la
1 es cinco o visto recuerda en el otro
lenguaje de logaritmos logaritmo en base
5 de 5 es igual a 15 elevado a qué
potencia me da sin
y la respuesta es una y por último si
tenemos que llevarle 2x vale 25 5 al
cuadrado es igual a 25 y vamos a ponerlo
también en lenguaje de logaritmos
logaritmo en base 5 de 25 es igual a 25
elevado a la potencia 2 es lo mismo que
25 visto en su forma exponencial y
fíjate cómo nos sirvió bastante ver el
problema inverso es decir pensar en la
exponencial y en esta función variar la
jr y obtener los ciertos valores de x y
con estos valores claros de llegó
obtuvimos unos ciertos valores claros de
x mientras que si yo habría puesto
números al azar en x nos hubiéramos
topado con un problema mucho más difícil
en el cual seguramente tendríamos que
utilizar la calculadora para obtener los
valores de y entonces pues ahora sí
hablemos de gráficas y para esto pues
voy a dibujar mis dos ejes date cuenta
que va de menos 2 a 2 y que x siempre es
positivo por lo tanto voy a dibujar unos
seresco ordenados que cumplen eso así
que no voy a tomar a este comité de
leyes este de aquí y después no voy a
tomar aquí el medio al eje de las x este
de aquí va a ser
mi eje de las equis y crece para acá
crece para acá y este es mi eje de las
equis y si te das cuenta que toma
valores de menos 2 menos 10 1 y 2
por lo tanto 0 1 2 y para abajo -1 y -2
me va a quedar bien padre la gráfica y
ahora vamos a pensar en x date cuenta
que x siempre toma valores positivos
esto es importantísimo sea cual sea el
valor que tú le des ayer siempre vas a
obtener una x positiva el logaritmo
nunca está definido para números
negativos o más aún cuando x vale 0
entonces el logaritmo en base 5 de 0
podemos decir que es menos infinito para
acercarnos a 0 en x tendremos que tomar
un valor muy pero muy pero muy pero muy
pequeño pero inclusive en cero tampoco
está definida en mi función por lo tanto
puedo decir con certeza que x siempre
tiene que ser positivo y es bastante
bueno pensar en esto porque estamos
pensando en el dominio de nuestra
función y nuestro dominio está definido
para las x mayores que 0 así queda como
escribir o para acá abajo
dominio de esta función es las equis que
son mayores que cero muy bien ahora date
cuenta que puede variar de cualquier
valor a cualquier valor pero bueno ya
que nos dimos cuenta que aquí siempre
tiene que ser positiva ahora sí vamos a
graficar los puntos y entonces vamos a
darle escala a x 5 10 15 20 y llegamos
hasta 25 y el primer punto que tengo es
cuando x vale un 25 ago lleva el de
menos 2 es decir cuando x está muy muy
pegadito al cero puede suponer que
estamos por aquí que vale menos dos así
que tengo este punto que voy a dibujar
justo aquí y voy a decir que este es el
punto un 25 como menos dos cuando x vale
un 25 a borge vale menos 2 perfecto ya
tengo el primer punto de esta gráfica y
date cuenta que estamos muy pegados al
cero pero no tengamos el cero y después
dice cuando x vale un quinto ya vale
menos uno así que estamos por aquí este
es el punto un quinto coma menos uno así
que vamos a poner el siguiente punto y
el siguiente punto dice que cuando x
vale uno lleva de cero estamos justo
aquí esto
10 y ahora vámonos con el tercer con el
cuarto punto que es este de aquí x 51
cuando x vale 5 que toma el valor de 1
es este punto que tenemos bien marcado y
bien definido aquí el punto 5 1 y para
finalizar tenemos el punto 25 2 es este
punto que tenemos aquí cuando x vall de
25 lleva le 2 estamos en el punto 25,2
el punto 25 2 y bueno pues ahora voy a
tomar un color que me guste para que yo
pueda graficar estos puntos para unir
estos puntos y voy a tomar este rosa que
tengo aquí y entonces cada vez que
déjame empezar cada vez que yo tome un
valor muy pero muy pero muy pequeño en x
voy a obtener un valor cada vez más
negativo en quien por ejemplo si me tomo
el valor de x de punto 0 000 0 000 1
entonces voy a obtener un valor muy pero
muy negativo en bien entonces que esto
va creciendo por aquí después por acá
empieza a crecer más empieza a crecer y
mi gráficas
hacia la derecha sigue hasta acá y por
acá abajo también sigue sin embargo hay
que tener mucho cuidado es una gráfica
que va a ir bajando a ver bajando a ver
bajando se vaya acercando al eje de la
siesta pero nunca va a tocar al eje de
las 10 así que déjenme hacer este eje
por aquí y mi gráfica se va a ir pegando
cada vez más al eje de la chaise pero
nunca lo va a tocar